I hope and I don't mean this lightly but
but I hope that when I think about my
contribution legacy that the first thing
is that my kids will say you know dad
was pretty good guy and and and will
quote me you know in as in dad always
used to say or I remember sometime when
dad said that would be one piece I
remember going to roam the first time
and making a point of seeing Keats's
grave and weeping at Keats's grave and I
did because you know there is I mean he
craved immortality and on his tombstone
is written here lies one whose name was
writ in water and you never know whether
Keats was you know actually thought that
or whether he was doing that figuring
that by doing that you know sort of like
taking an umbrella so it wouldn't rain
whether he was that was a protection or
whether he was whether whether it was
just false modesty but but I'd like to
think that in some of the work that I've
done both in my own writing and as the
editor of HBR that there will be a few
things that have changed some
organizations for the better and when I
was at fortunate before coming to HBR i
wrote two books about intellectual
capital and about the value of knowledge
and the importance of thinking of
knowledge and organizations and
developing knowledge assets and
developing use in tapping into people's
brains and creativity of worth and those
have had an influence I think along with
a lot of other things I may have
contributed to that but I also i hope
that in that work and in the work I've
done at HBR they'll be some people who
say you know that article or that idea
that that that changed things that that
gave people some stuff that made some
lives better or in even ideally some
organizations you know change change the
practice
of management in some permanent way so
that we stop screwing things up quite as
often as we do